النجم عبد المجيد عبد الله كمان احيا
حفلتين استثنائيتين في ليلتين وراء بعض
الخميس والجمعه حفلات استثنائيه من كل
النواحي مثل ما تعودنا منه اقبال جنوني
على التذاكر وتفاعل كبير خلال الحفل وبعده
طبعا كمان التفاعل والطلب كان لدرجه تم
الاعلان فيها عن ليله الثالثه لعبد المجيد
عبد الله هتكون يوم 20 يناير والتذاكر
ستطرح قريبا والموضوع وصل له معالي
المستشار تركي ال الشيخ طلب من اللي حضر
ما يرجع يشتري تذاكر ويعطي فرصه لغيره
لانه عارف طبعا انه معجبين عبد المجيد
مستعدين يروحوا يحضروا 10 ايام وراء بعض
وما يملؤه ومع صوت عبد المجيد عبد الله
راح نختم حلقاتنا اليوم وانا اعود والقاكم
غدا ان شاء الله في امان الله
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
روحي جرح
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
من
[تصفيق]
يصدق الفراق
اناديها
رد الصداقه
[موسيقى]
يشبهك
جمالا عجيب
[تصفيق]
انت حل
شخصيتك
اوقف امام مرايتي
واحبني
واحكيلي وش سوى الزمان
وش حيلتي لا صرتيلي